bonjour mes côtés je vais vous parler
d'un mythe gaulois qui pourrait devenir
réalité
parce qu'en fait nous sommes urbain vous
et moi et nous avons souvent oublié le
lien entre agriculture climat et
alimentation hors d'eux fait ce lien
redevient réel il suffit de voir la
grêle qui tombent sur des vignes où
certains delta du monde dans lesquels
l'inondation chasse des millions de
personnes alors je voudrais vous parler
de ce que c'est la sécurité alimentaire
de chacun dans le monde
et puis du lien entre cette sécurité
alimentaire et le team a dès aujourd'hui
et puis peut-être imaginer avec vous ce
que pourrait être l'alimentation futur
dans un contexte fort de changement
climatique
alors comme je suis ingénieur j'aime
bien commencer par des chiffres pour
essayer de de décrire cette ce phénomène
extraordinaire qui s'est passé entre
1960 et 2000 est ce que vous avez en
tête qu'en 1960 nous étions 3 milliard
d'habitants
on le dit maintenant plus souvent
qu'avant et que en 2000 nous étions 6
milliards donc dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
il s'est passé quelque chose de jamais
vu évidemment le doublement et avec des
chiffres jamais vu sur la planète c'est
ce qui explique qu'on se met à parler
d'environnement qu'on se met à parler de
l'état de la planète
et quand vous regardez ce qui s'est
passé comme évolution pour la production
agricole en parallèle vous voyez que
dans le monde pendant que la population
doubler la population la production
agricole grâce à la révolution verte
était multiplié par 2,4
avec évidemment des performances
extrêmement différente selon les régions
voyez que dans certaines régions en asie
la croissance c'est énorme dans d'autres
régions comme l'ex urss les événements
politiques qui évidemment ont conduit à
une autre évolution
quoi qu'il arrive en théorie aujourd'hui
il y a sur la planète de quoi nourrir
l'ensemble des habitants présents
évidemment la réalité tout autre puisque
vous avez 800 millions de personnes qui
ont encore passé à manger deux milliards
de personnes qui ont des déficiences en
tel ou tel élément
alors que se passe-t-il c'est que la
sécurité alimentaire c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué c'est bien sûr d'avoir assez
de production et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
mais c'est aussi que ces productions
soit saine qu'elle ne soit pas
dangereuse pour la santé ça peut être
des microbes ça peut être des
contaminants ça peut être des
moisissures
il faut surtout et ça ça a été dit très
bien par mme al ahmadiah saigne le prix
nobel que les personnes aient accès à
cette alimentation accès ça peut être
une difficulté d'accès physique c'est
dans les zones de guerre et les zones de
crise que les gens enfin en général ou
un accès économique
sire que les choses sont trop chers et
que je ne pouvais pas les acheter et
puis le dernier phénomène très important
vous l'avez vu c'est depuis 2005
seulement
c'est cette amplitude beaucoup plus
grande de volatilité des prix qui peut
poser problème
parce qu'évidemment quand les prix
augmentent certaines personnes n'ont pas
accès économique ne peuvent plus les
personnes pauvres ne peut plus ne
peuvent plus acheter à manger et c'est
ce qui s'est passé en 2008 vous souvenez
peut-être d'avoir entendu parler de ces
émeutes de la faim qui savait démarré en
egypte pourquoi en egypte d'abord parce
que c'était en ville et qui avaient des
journalistes en ville les gens qui ont
faim à la campagne ça fait toujours
moins de bruit dans les médias
et ensuite parce que les urbains pauvres
ne pouvaient plus acheter le blé qui
était nécessaire pour leurs familles
alors de fait c'est une situation qui a
conduit à des crises graves dans 32 pays
du monde et c'est un phénomène
relativement nouveau comme vous l'avez
vu tout à l'heure ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'au fond les gens avaient
l'habitude que l'alimentation ça
devienne quelque chose de naturellement
disponible et partout dans le monde les
stocks ont diminué
et quand les stocks diminuent ça veut
dire que si vous avez le moindre
accident et vous n'êtes pas capables en
sortant des denrées des stocks
d'atténuer les chocs et par exemple
lorsqu'un choc climatique en 2007 en
australie et une chaise une sécheresse
énorme
l'australie est un des grands
exportateurs de blé dans le monde
metz a une influence sur les cours
mondiaux il vous avez vu tout à l'heure
les cours du blé notamment qui ont
augmenté extrêmement rapidement
à ce moment là est donc aujourd'hui on
commence à avoir un lien très direct
depuis les années 2000 en lien très
direct entre eux la production agricole
le climat est donc les capacités de
s'alimenter
alors je voulais vous parler de la
situation générale
de fait dès aujourd'hui les rendements
delà je vous ai représenter les
rendements au fond de deux denrées de
base avec le blé le maïs et le riz vous
avez la base de l'alimentation de
l'humanité et bien d'ores et déjà et
pour le maïs et pour le blé dans le
monde entier vous avez des diminutions
de rendement or je voulais dit tout à
l'heure si on peut aujourd'hui mieux
manger qu'en 1960 c'est parce que la
production agricole a augmenté plus vite
que la population et la demande va
continuer à augmenter parce que la
population va continuer à augmenter et
par ailleurs les classes moyennes
augmenter quand les gens commencent à
avoir un niveau de vie suffisant
il demande à manger plus et puis après
ils demandent à manger des divers et
puis après ils demandent à manger d or
des denrées d'origine animale et sa
demande se fait de plus en plus appel à
la production dans le monde
donc il ya un vrai problème
d'inadéquation des tendances actuelles
des rendements agricoles avec cette
situation climatique mondial qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pour nous mais pour nous d'ores et
déjà en france c'est vrai on vous l'avez
vu les rendements diminuent et donc ça
pose des problèmes aux producteurs mais
dans d'autres pays comme ceux que je
mentionne ici les pays pauvres du monde
ça pose des problèmes bien amplifié
parce que dans ces pays pauvres la
majorité du budget des personnes est
consacré à l'alimentation 78% 75% 74%
on a complètement oublié cette situation
chez nous et on doit en être à 14% chez
nous mais dans des pays dans lesquels
les gens ont peu l'alimentation c'est la
dépense numéro 1 et à ce moment là vous
voyez bien dès que les prix augmentent
ça devient un vrai problème existentiel
pour la plupart des populations
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
l'avenir
d'ores et déjà donc les spécialistes du
changement climatique ont essayé de
comprendre ce qui pourrait arriver ce
sont les rapports du giec le dernier
rapport de mars 2014 sur les impacts
qu'on constate d'ores et déjà en matière
agricole et en matière d'alimentation en
2050 on nous dit que la température et
les précipitations pourraient changer
encore plus on nous parle de 4°
éventuellement en matière de température
les par ailleurs le niveau de la mer va
augmenter les glaciers vont continuer à
fondre les nappes phréatiques vont
changer de niveau et les débits des
rivières vont diminuer
donc ça fait beaucoup de change en au
changement de condition physique dans
lesquelles les activités de production
vont s'exercer
ça veut dire bien sûr qu'il faut adapter
les variétés adaptées les modes de
culture adapter les modes d'alimentation
des populations pour résister à ces
évolutions prévisibles et en tant que
scientifique au fond qu'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire
on essaye toujours de dessiner les
futures possibles vous savez un peu
comme dans les livres de science fiction
quels sont les scénarios possibles
quelles sont les conséquences de ces
scénarios quelles sont les conséquences
qu'on voudrait éviter et donc quel
chemin chercheront nous a favorisés au
fond nous on est là pour dire le roi est
nu ou le roy préfère faire autre chose
et puis tout aux décideurs de décider et
puis se trouve que dans ma carrière j'ai
aussi été parfois en situation de
conseiller des politiques pour les
politiques publiques à mettre en place
c'est par exemple je viens de faire un
rapport sur l'agroécologie sert comment
construire des systèmes agricoles plus
performants vis-à-vis à la fois de
l'économie et de l'environnement
eh bien ça suppose bien sûr des
changements de pratiques des acteurs
mais ça suppose aussi un cadre de
politique publique qui évolue alors vous
allez me dire tout ça ça nous concerne
de loin mais je voudrais vous dire que
ça vous concerne vous tous nous tous qui
sommes dans cette salle très directement
parce que le premier facteur qui va vous
dire ce qu'il faudra et s'il y aura
assez à manger pour l'humanité dans les
années à venir le premier facteur ce
sera ce qu'on mange
si on continue à évoluer en matière
d'alimentation comme dans les pays de
céder aujourd'hui il faudra augmenter la
production agricole de 30%
on voit bien que c'est faisable avec un
peu de superficie en plus et en
continuant à progresser par l'innovation
et la recherche
si on part dans si on suppose que dans
chaque région du monde on veut que tout
le monde ait accès à 3000 kcal par
personne et par jour et ça suffit un
3000 collecte kcal c'est ce qui permet
de d'être en bonne santé en moyenne 1
évidemment un nourrisson ne mange pas la
même chose qu'une personne en pleine
forme dont 500 kcal d'origine animale et
bien tout à l'heure je vous disais que
il fallait augmenter de 80 % la
production agricole si on produisait on
continue à consommer comme aujourd'hui
si on consomme juste qu'il nous faut
pour être en bonne santé
en plus on se maintient en bonne santé
et bien l'augmentation de la production
agricole les cje avait inversé les
chiffres tout à l'heure ne nécessaire
n'est que de 30%
donc c'est vous dire selon le régime
alimentaire que vous allez adopter selon
les régimes alimentaires qui vont être
adoptés dans le monde
selon ce que favoriseront nos
organisations sociales ce sera différent
je vous donne un exemple les la satiété
vous savez quand vous avez l'impression
de ne plus avoir faim
est ce que vous saviez que ça dépend de
la taille de votre assiette si vous avez
une grande assiette mais vous aurez une
impression de satiété beaucoup plus tard
que si vous avez une petite assiette
parce que la satiété c'est non seulement
un effet physiologique mais c'est en
effet dans le cerveau donc le fait de
diminuer la taille des assiettes may et
c sont des choses extrêmement simple qui
permettrait d'éviter des
surconsommations un autre exemple sont
les pertes des gaspillages
actuellement on perd et on gaspille dans
le monde à peu près temps tard à 40% de
ce qui est produit est bien de fait je
peux vous donner un exemple d'une école
dans lequel les enfants gaspiller du
parle de pincer la première denrées
gaspillé dans les systèmes collectifs et
le directeur a eu l'idée de mettre un
poulailler à côté de l'école et les
enfants tous les jours dans des petits
sauts deviens devait amener à manger aux
poules puis s'il trouvait quand même que
c'était lourd et c'était un sacré boulot
les deux fêtes les pertes ont diminué de
30% simplement par la prise de
conscience des enfants voilà tout ça
pour vous dire que on sait que l'avenir
sera différent l'important maintenant
c'est d'être prêt en être des acteurs
merci de votre attention